if you're wondering how to get started
with bioinformatics you have come to the
right place in this short video i will
show you how to find courses example
projects and mentor guided training
programs that will set you on track to
learn about bioinformatics from the very
beginning
mastering the terminology used in this
domain and practicing to apply
bioinformatics analysis methods to real
data sets
so how do you get all of this together
in one single place let me show you to
get started register for free on
learnomicslogic.com
after you register you will be
redirected to the courses tab where you
can search for any course title use the
tags to find series of resources around
a topic or choose one of the collections
here down below
in this video we will look at the
getting started collection
this collection brings together several
basic courses that will introduce
bioinformatics applications in
healthcare biomedical research
biotechnology and agriculture
provides you with a concise overview of
various biological concepts you need to
know to understand omix data and it will
also introduce you to some basic
functions in popular coding languages
such as r and python
now these few courses were taken from
the core omics logic curriculum
available online if you want to see more
simply explore these modules and find
the right next step with exercises that
you can practice but ultimately we are
going to get to the real projects
because ultimately the methods are best
learned in the context of a real case
study that is prepared by our network of
mentors and collaborators and illustrate
how various bioinformatics methods and
omix data types are used in current
research and medicine biotechnology
agriculture and even astrobiology these
datasets and associated publications can
be used in several different ways you
can learn bioinformatics without any
coding at all for that in each project
you can learn how to analyze data using
pipelines on the user-friendly tb info
platform
you can also learn the scripts behind
many of these steps learning to wrangle
clean visualize and analyze data in
popular languages like r and python and
finally you can hear about the projects
and the research applications in our
mentor guided programs where experts
share their experience and support
research projects developed by you
now over the course of the past several
years our team has been collaborating
with a number of academic institutions
around the world that have participated
in content evaluation curriculum review
and project design and as a result the
onyx logic programs have been thoroughly
evaluated and are now known to lead to
excellent outcomes
so as a result we have thousands of
users from all over the world and from
all sorts of backgrounds that have taken
and evaluated each one of these courses
providing us with feedback that we used
to improve and polish up a lot of the
resources that we have to view the full
path and get started explore these links
and go to the learn portal to get
started right away